does it for Christ's ish car tester
Klaus needs Fitz is trying out the gt3
RS the latest version of Porsches
best-selling 911 carrera line RS stands
for racing sports and the car lives up
to that there's lots of changes the body
is wider by 50 millimetres in front and
30 and back the rear wing is bigger for
greater downforce and the front wheel
air vents diverts about one-third of the
downforce onto the front axle the car
puts out some 500 horsepower but that's
not all
Klaus takes the gt3 out onto the
racetrack where it's truly in its
element more than any other 911 this
model gives you a pure hi a real racing
field output is 368 kilowatts generating
460 newton meters of torque Adam makes
the sprint from zero to 100 in just 3.3
seconds in the RS you can switch off ESP
and traction control entirely
but even when you leave them switched on
in the interest of safety the
performance is impressive
what about me few Klaus knows he's the
envy of many a Porsche fan it's not
everyone who gets a chance to take the
new 911 gt3 RS out for a spin on the
billster bag track though it's just four
kilometers long it's a piece of work
only hats automatic NZ first he turns
off all the electronic driving
assistance options pittock and switches
pdk sport on traction control is off now
it's pure driving just him and the car
extra track width at the front and rear
axles make for enhanced ability as do
the tires the widest on any 911 model
that adds up to greater mechanical grip
and even higher speeds through the
curves
but even so Klaus says this car is still
suited for everyday driving you can
cruise the highways or head off to
dusseldorf hamburg Berlin or Frankfurt
for shopping it's a car that fits most
every lifestyle einsatz polite so
despite its athleticism the 368 kilowatt
output and a top speed of 310 kilometers
an hour the gt3 RS is a good all-rounder
the pdk dual-clutch gearbox takes care
of the shifting
so please close as the car masters s
curves perfectly even with the pedal to
the metal and 230 km/h downshifting for
a fast left curve you can really feel
the cars excellent balance and that also
has to do with all the downforce the gt3
RS is without doubt an exceptional
sports car the body includes the
aerodynamic add-ons typical of the RS
models and the extra width really
emphasizes its Motorsports pedigree
the interior design is portia through
and through carbon fiber sport bucket
seats offer firm support under extreme
conditions the Alcantara steering wheel
was taken from the hybrid super sports
car 918 spyder and some klaus says this
car drives like a bona fide racecar but
you can still take it grocery shopping
the downside is the price at almost one
hundred eighty two thousand euros in
Germany but that buys you a car that's a
joy to drive to open the console mega
flash pass the Porsche 911 gt3 RS is a
race car for street driving it's a car
with one single goal to be the fastest
car on the road
you